LAURA LING (VOICEOVER):
I've traveled
the world working
as a journalist
and international reporter.
LAURA LING: They're trying to
restore control, restore order.
You can see the bullet
casings right here.
LAURA LING (VOICEOVER): I
think that I have tried hard
to shine a light on issues that
need the world's attention.
LAURA LING: In March of 2009 I
traveled to Northeastern China
to report on a story about
North Korean defectors.
And it was while we were filming
along the frozen Tumen river
that we were chased down
by North Korean soldiers.
Everything just
happened so quickly.
I was eventually
knocked unconscious
and dragged into North Korea.
It was the scariest
time of my life.
I was isolated in
what is perhaps
the most isolated
country in the world.
It was very easy for these
dark thoughts to invade my mind
and spiral me into a depression.
I thought that I had failed
the North Korean refugees
that I had gone to cover.
I felt that I had
failed my family.
I did know about various vigils
that were taking place for us
across the country and in
other parts of the world.
In very dark moments, I would
think about those lights.
Seconds there seem
like an eternity.
But there was
something that I began
to do that helped me
get through each day.
And it was a very simple act.
It was practicing
the act of gratitude.
And I just started doing it one
day, where I was sitting down
and I thought to
myself, Laura think
about something that happened
today that you can actually
feel grateful for, despite
this horrible situation
that you're in.
And so I would say to
myself, for example,
I feel lucky I saw a
butterfly outside my window,
even though I can't
breathe the fresh air.
I feel grateful that I got to
go outside for a few moments
and see the sun and feel
the warmth on my skin.
Getting letters
from my family, I
memorized each and every word.
Doing this definitely was a
turning point for me mentally.
I think that there
was a point where
I was only thinking about
the negative possibilities.
That I wouldn't see
my family again.
That I wouldn't
ever have children.
That I would spend the rest
of my life in that country.
But being able to focus on some
of those glimmers of light,
it really did help
give me the strength
to look at each new day
as a new possibility.
After I came home,
I actually continued
to practice this
act of gratitude.
And it's a ritual
that I do to this day.
And I do it as a reminder
of the things that
are important in my life.
Things that I want to
cherish and treasure.
Because this ritual had
such an impact on me
and who I am today,
I want explore
the rituals of other people.
To understand and learn
about these practices that
have helped others get through
their struggles and obstacles,
and have really helped
define who they are.
And so I hope that
this series is
this inspirational look into
what drives the human spirit.
LAURA LING
(VOICEOVER): "Rituals"
is a part of "Seeker Stories."
If you'd like to
continue to see more
stories from around the world,
we need you to subscribe.
Click to watch this
next episode where
one family leaves everything
behind to go off the grid.
LAURA LING: much do you
have riding on this,
for this to work?
NICK FOUCH: This is kind
of everything that I have.
I don't really have
a plan B. I don't
know how I would go back now.